rejected erdogan has pledged to bring
down turkey's soaring inflation under
pressure from the president turkey's
central bank has slashed rates in recent
months triggering a currency crisis our
correspondent yulia hahn reports from
istanbul
menji has to print new prize stickers
milk eggs toilet paper
almost everything he sells in his small
shop in istanbul's kariko district has
become more expensive again
take this pack of pasta for example a
year ago i sold it for 3.5 liras now it
costs more than twice as much that's not
normal
manufacturers and wholesalers are hiking
prices several times a month
and dearmenji has to do the same
sometimes he says he is barely able to
keep up
[Music]
i've been a shopkeeper for 10 years but
i've never seen anything like this
right now the wholesalers don't make a
profit i'm not making a profit and the
customers suffer too nobody wins
everyone is losing
[Music]
all around the world nations are
grappling with rising inflation due to
the coronavirus pandemic and higher
energy costs
but the price spikes here in turkey have
been exacerbated by a dramatic
depreciation of the country's currency
the lira
according to official figures
inflation has soared to 36 percent
that's the highest rate in nearly 20
years
yet many think that even this
eye-popping figure is an understatement
i think inflation is higher everything
got at least twice or three times as
expensive
we know exactly what we are paying at
the supermarket i think it's 50 or more
i was like
i've been running around for two hours
trying to find cheap bread
i think we are seeing 100 inflation
right now
on social media too anger about the
price explosion is growing this twitter
account with more than 100 000 followers
is called inflation diary users post
photos showing changing price tags in
grocery stores
have so far been unsuccessful
nevertheless he says he is convinced
that prices will soon fall
economist
disagrees she projects that inflation
will likely rise further eroding incomes
and savings
towards the end of the first quarter we
will see inflation rates of 50 to 60
percent
the real problem is that president
erdogan thinks he is the chief economist
here in the country and everyone else
doesn't know anything
that will only change with an election
and a new government
the next elections in turkey aren't
officially due until twenty twenty three
shop owner foreign does not know what
will happen in the meantime
but he knows one thing for sure the next
price hike will definitely come
let's discuss the situation in turkey
further with economist john salcuki he
joins us from istanbul thanks for being
with us on dw business can you just
explain to us why when inflation is such
a big problem in many parts of the world
at the moment it is so severe in turkey
well the prima the fundamental reason is
the causes of inflation is not being
dealt with currently by economic
management neither by you know or the
monetary policy
so you know as long as the underlying
effects of of this soaring inflation is
not dealt with it's not reasonable to
expect the inflation to go down and
obviously at the at the core of the
issue is the depreciated lira as the
turkish economy already dependent uh
largely on on fx currencies for
for production uh also um
the the the dolarization is increasing
and the trust in the economy overall is
decreasing and this has an effect not
only prices
uh
through the pass-through of the currency
but also uh through the increase in
producers costs which in effect uh
impacts the
prices for the
consumers so this is a downward spiral
and
as long as these drivers are not dealt
with
there's no reason to expect
the inflation to go down yeah i mean the
approach you're talking about there is
president erdogan's unconventional
belief that low interest rates will
tackle inflation
why does he have this unconventional
idea how to handle the situation
i think uh there's
growth at all costs is prioritized seems
to have been prioritized at the at the
moment and low interest rates uh with a
depreciated lira that would you know
provide a competitive edge for turkish
exports uh is believed to uh you know uh
incentivize investment and drive
exports up however you know this this
aim to provide oxygen for the private
sector uh
in you know by lowering attack
lowering interest rates actually has
quite the opposite effect right now the
official uh interest rate is very
different from uh what the real sector
loan rates
so
in effect this whole thing drives up
producers manufacturers costs so
it's actually resulting in the opposite
direction
so
just briefly if you can is there any
hope without a radical change in
approach of inflation actually being
tackled in turkey
anything short of a complete policy
reversal i see it very difficult for
inflation to go down as i said if you
don't deal with the drivers
then it's it's not reasonable to expect
the result to change
okay chancellor key thank you very much
for joining us on dw business
my pleasure